a lot of people say that math is hard
as a kind of negative statement
it always seemed to me a little bit like
that's kind of a positive statement
that all things that are worth having in
this world
are hard i mean everything that people
think about
that they would love to do whether it's
sports
whether it's art music
and all the sciences they're going to be
hard if you want to do something special
so is there something you could say to
that idea that math is hard
should it be made easy or should it be
hard
ah so i think maybe i want to dig in a
little bit onto this hard part
and say i think the interesting thing
about the math
is that you can see a question that you
didn't know how to
start doing it before and over a course
of
thinking about it you can come up with a
way
to to solve it and so you can move from
a state of
not being able to do something to a
state of being able to do something
where you help to take yourself through
that instead of somebody else
spoon feeding you yes that technique so
actually here i'm already digging into
maybe part of my teaching philosophy
also which is that
i actually don't want to ever just tell
somebody
here's how you do something i actually
prefer to say here's an interesting
question
i know you don't quite know how to do it
do you have any ideas
this is i'm actually coming up with i'm
actually explaining another way that you
could try to do teaching
and i'm contrasting this to a method of
watch me do this
now practice it 20 times i'm trying to
say a lot of people
consider math to be hard because maybe
they can't remember all of the methods
that were taught
but for me i look at the hardness and i
don't think of it as a memory hardness
i think of it as a can you invent
something hardness
and i think that if we can teach more
people how to do that
art of invention in a pure cognitive way
not as hard as the
actual hardware stuff right but like in
terms of the concepts and the thoughts
and the mathematics
teaching people how to invent then
suddenly
actually they might not even find math
to be that
tiresomeness hard anymore right but that
rewardingness hard of
i have the capability of looking at
something which i don't know what to do
and coming up with how to do it i
actually think we should be doing that
giving giving people that capability